what's goody hopper at the verse welcome
back to hot breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros i'm your host
comedian joel byers and after 400
interviews on this show our mission is
to cultivate the next generation of
great comics by interviewing today's
great comics and our guest today is
definitely one of those great comics
with over 20 years of comedy experience
that all started after he was seeing
eddie murphy's raw when he was nine
years old the first show
he did was actually a comedy contest
where he ended up going to the
semifinals from there he started doing
bringer shows while doing door-to-door
sales and now he's released a netflix
special directed by pete davidson yes
when is this coming out by the way this
will come out to promote the special
okay so we'll it'll already be announced
i'm thinking so yeah yeah yeah yeah
i figured i would release this one win
the special that's perfect to promote it
yes yes yeah okay okay okay it was on
your website well you do a lot of uh you
did a lot of homework there like of
course yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like you you brought me back when you
were like door knocking you brought me
back you brought me back to queens at 6
30 at night on a weekday being told get
the [__] off my front steps and uh yeah
but yeah that's that's all true all that
[__] you're trying to you were selling
like phone internet yeah it was like
five right it was there was a it was a
company called rcn and they did phone
cable internet like through fiber optics
and stuff so it was like you combined
all your bill on one you get the phone
you get the modem you get all that stuff
yeah yeah i was doing that i was doing
that in uh manhattan first and then
queens door to door dude i would knock
on somebody's door at dinner time and be
like hey we just installed wires do you
want and you know and you dealt with
everything you dealt with
with rejection but some people invite
you in and give you something to drink
other people were like you know [__] off
and it was you just and you just got
immune to it but that guess it helps you
handle hecklers and stuff now if you can
you could handle that rejection you can
handle like knocking down a heckler yeah
you know what i found in this is it's
just experience where
you're always going to deal with
something and after enough times
you kind of learn why the heckle
happened
you learn
what type of heckle it is
and what type of person is doing the
heckling
and when you know all that you can gauge
how you maneuver through it
yeah it was amazing to watch you here
last night i'm so glad i got to see you
three times this weekend
is like last night was just one of those
late friday shows that we all know that
like people can be hammered but you
handled it in a way that it's like you
never really like
neglected anyone you like you had fun
with them but you're also making sure
that they knew what the deal was okay
okay let's go back to the jokes here and
then you ended up doing like
you did like 75 minutes and i was like i
bet after 45 he's gonna be like all
right i'm clocking out but you like
stuck with them and then you brought
them all around and at like minute 50
like a shift happened to where like
everyone was like alright i guess we
should just sit here and enjoy it and
then you kept going man and to see you
effortlessly
go
70 minutes plus every show i was just
like yo
it's like when you see a really good
comic and you're like oh
that's where the level is like at 12
years in i'm like sometimes it's awesome
and then you see people like you and
you're like oh there's so much to do
well first of all i really really
appreciate that and you said something
which lets me know that you are very uh
knowledgeable about this i know you've
been doing comedy 12 years but yeah so
last night i told somebody today i said
last night's second show was one of the
most memorable i've had because
because or or in that i should say most
memorable i had in that kind of aren't
like in that area yeah yeah because
um yeah it was a type of show where it
was rowdy it was loud they were drunk
they were somewhat disrespectful and
then i got the light at 40 and i could
just get out i could get out yeah and
and i was like no i'm gonna be defiant
here and i've been doing this long
enough so then you know people coming up
to me last night going wow dude like the
last 20 minutes of that was like you
used you you like using their stuff
against them
to then you know to have them stand up
at the end and do all that was pretty
was pretty cool so i was happy with that
because i'll take a show like that means
more than when there's like a perfect
packed house everything is good because
you know kind of the outcome not not not
in an arrogant way but you know like
when all the things are good
right the crowd's in it's packed
everyone's happy they're fans they want
to hear what you have to say it's good
you know where with something like last
night it was like all right let's go
let's go into a little battle i like to
see the cage fights yeah i like to see
comics who like you nailed what happened
last night pretty perfectly wow it was
it was fun to watch man just to see the
work and like i in researching you like
you referenced i heard you say that it
took you like 10 and a half years to
find your voice yeah what was what what
was like the moment or like what do you
mean by like 10 and a half years and now
you're like oh here's my voice like what
was the
well i think it would have been quicker
if i didn't have like
you know i i was home and i had kids and
and you know i was told no a lot in this
business dude nobody cared about me in
this business until about 14 years in
once i got montreal and then after
montreal like certain things happened
and uh you know but um
yeah you know i had a family i was
married young again and that will never
hurt you because it's all in the comic
doesn't matter when people say oh you've
got a family that's got to be tough no
it's not it's it's you know it'll drive
you really and it should drive you you
know um but
i don't know at early on i just wasn't
able to be in the city as much
but going back to what you said at ten
and a half years it just got to the
point where
i just not that you don't care but
you're you're
you kind of have done it where you're
like you know you're you're funny
right you know you're funny but what
happens i think when you is just like
trusting yourself
just trust it you know where you can't
really trust it year one two three
because you don't know right you don't
know if you're that funny or if you're
funny and then you're like oh maybe i'm
funny to some people but when it got to
a point where i've been through a lot of
experiences and i was like really
starting to kill and i was able to you
know open up for people like you know i
remember i opened up one weekend in
north carolina for david tell i opened
for jim brewer you know went on the road
a bunch with bill burr uh and and and
when all of those start to go well and
you just kind of get your confidence up
you know i don't know if you ever like
played in basketball game but like if
you play basketball and you hit your
first shot like oh good then you hit
your second shot you're like oh [__]
then you start hitting shots and you're
like i'm [__] michael jordan and and
you're just like i'm the best player on
this court and like i might not miss
again and you get to but but that
happens in comedy where you're just like
oh dude that joke and this joke and you
kind of really start to gain your
confidence confidence is obviously you
have to be talented and [__] but
confidence is a lot and i gained it and
i just started trusting my myself and i
remember i i don't know if it was louis
c.k or somebody said when you could be
your funny self off stage on
on stage you're always going to be a
little exaggerated maybe or get it but
but if you could just kind of be who you
are and how you really feel you know so
so that's what you meant when you like
found your voices it was more like a
confidence that you were starting to
perform with not maybe specific topics
you were starting to cover well i think
it was a little bit of both i think i
think both come together
i think when you have confidence you're
able to now throw out a topic that you
might have been scared of yeah yeah
right because you just hit three jump
shots
right so you just hit three jump shots
tonight you're like well [__] i'm gonna
try this four because i keep hitting
them so let me so i think that when your
confidence goes up you're able to just
say you know what i will do a joke right
now about
you know
cancer charities or i will do a joke
right now about a disease or or or a
disability somebody may have i'm gonna
try to do it in the best way i could but
i trust myself that i could do it that's
what started to happen oh okay you start
to not get upset
with the crowd being upset
or you start to get you you're not upset
with some people being upset
because because what happens is i
noticed as i got better there were more
pockets of people that didn't like me
because if everybody's liking me then
i'm being safe
yeah well i mean opening up for someone
like bill burr for so many years i'm
sure really like you're seeing it at
that level as you're developing as well
of like oh okay
you say these things that some people
may get upset about and by the end of it
they're laughing at it you know you know
i remember i opened for patrice o'neil
rest his soul and bananas i opened for
patrice bananas one weekend and i
remember like people were like walking
out and he would have people walk out
and i was young not able to really
understand why is he doing that why is
he but i realized what he was doing he
was he they were never gonna be fans
anyway like weed them out because i'm
gonna say so like then i worked at him
another time where i did a guest spot in
the city and i saw how really that's
when i really saw how brilliant he was i
got to tell him that and one of the
coolest things ever was i got to tell
patrice and i go dude i go i don't know
you know i know i knew you were good but
then i pointed to the room at comics in
new york city i said but i didn't know
you were that good and he left he liked
it because like i didn't realize like
you you're if you walk somebody and it's
because you said something honest and
they just didn't like it that's fine
you don't know that when you're young
you're scared why are they leaving
people aren't gonna like me then you're
like [__] who cares yeah but sometimes
young comics are like oh i see people
that have been doing this 30 years cover
these like risky topics and they're like
two months in like no i'm the chosen one
i'm going to say these things and it's
not funny and then people get offended
and they're like what is this and then
they post a craney groud work clip
trying to go viral and they have nothing
to back it up yeah that's where the
game's at now but if it works it works
you know people are having success with
it but with your new special i heard you
talking about how like special you want
a special to be special like a lot of
people are putting out specials now and
it's like
and i mean a lot of them are good but i
ali sadiq just dropped a special
and i was talking with him about it and
he was and it was like a it was like it
just affected me because i haven't
really seen a special this good i mean
earthquake just dropped to one that was
dope too but
it really affected me in a way seeing
ali's because it's like amazing stories
but it's every line is like a laugh you
know and a lot of specials you know
they're
they have a little bit of flex in there
but he was like i want to be special
like what i used to think comedy
specials were and i've heard you
reference the same thing of specials
being actually special yeah i you know
and it's funny man ali sadiq and we
never met we know so i met somebody that
knows him but
every time i did something that went
viral on comedy central that was the
only dude on comedy central who had more
hits so like i got like 5.2 million and
then ali sadiq would be like 6 million
and it was always but like from what
i've seen of that guy just a monster and
and yeah and and i don't know how old he
is but i agree with that and that's what
i've been saying yeah you know um that's
what i've been saying josh it's like i
joe joel no you're good yeah sorry who's
josh john it's the other white guy it's
all good the other one guy you work with
oh no i don't work with any white people
i don't mess with white people no who's
there's a josh here though oh is there
yeah yeah i'm sorry so no you're good um
so what i was saying joel
was that uh
yeah there's just a lot of white guys
here so we all look the same no um
no but as far as a special being a
special
it really is like
for me it's and this is no disrespect to
somebody who does
a 30 minute special okay comedy central
and hbo did 30 minute specials so i'm
not knocking that but for me what i grew
up with and what i thought was special
was 60 minutes of joke after joke after
joke and what i really love is that
people that are watching my new special
nocturnal admissions which is it's
called um
people are like dude this is 60 minutes
of of jokes and this is just nonstop and
like to have amazing comedians and
amazing people that i really admire and
look up to and you know
respect say that means a lot but that's
what i expected to do like i didn't and
i'm not saying that an arrogant way it's
like i'm not gonna just be like yeah
we're in a time now where it's like oh
somebody's got a popular podcast and
like [__] it fans will come out and they
don't and it's like nah but fans will
come out but like that work is going to
stay there forever like that work is
going to be there forever so it's like
what do you want i don't do you want to
be the guy going yeah no but dude when i
did this the the podcast was hot
because that could happen you could be
30 years later let's say there's no
podcast
let's say there's nothing like no dude i
know it i know the material but dude my
podcast fans came out it's like yeah
okay the joke's [__] that you know so
so i that means it means a lot to me
that the body of work is is [__] good
why what how did pete davidson come
about to be like directing it and all
this how this relationship developed so
pete and i have been friends for a long
time you know uh pete had saw me
pete saw me uh
in new york city when he was like 16.
and i was you know i i think i was
opening for bill burke caroline's and i
just see this lanky kid and you know and
he was just and then i saw him again at
stand-up new york and he was like hey
man i love the podcast i didn't know it
was really nice and then um we had the
same manager at one point when we were
working the stand and we just were
friends and i put him on the versi
effect when he was 18 before everything
and we just stayed cool but like you
know he was we were talking and he's
like dude he's like i'd love to you know
direct your special
and uh then he told me one time he's
like dude you know like this is the best
[__] you've done and he was like you
know and he came out on stage the night
of the taping and he goes i saw paul at
16 and i saw him perform in the city and
he became one of my favorite comics and
he wanted to be a part of it you know
pete asked me you know we were hanging
out he's like i'd love to be a part of
it i love to put my name behind it and
and so you know pete is one of the best
most misunderstood kids i've said that
millions of times he's the [__] best
he's he's actually down to earth and the
sweetest he's so [__] cool and down
to earth like people would not believe
how [__] chill he is and cool and um
yeah man he's one of my best friends
he's one of them he's like a little
brother to me so um but yeah he he
wanted to be a part of it because of you
know as he was coming up he saw me and
he's like oh i want to do that that was
pretty cool wow and then like you said
reference that you were opening for bill
burr when into your career
you started in 2000
like how long into your career did you
start opening up for bill burr
so
yeah and how did that happen i i i did a
spot i
it was thanksgiving
weekend
in 2005 and bobby kelly came in for the
wednesday thanksgiving eve and then bill
came in on friday saturday and he was
just like dude you you know that was so
i he's like were you the other guy on
the show and he goes i was downstairs i
heard it you killed i'm going to watch
you so then he referred me to a room
and i did well there he heard i did well
at the room he referred me to he goes
hey how about next time i do that room
you work with me so then like around 07
we became we became friends and then i
remember one day in 2008 he goes hey i'm
going to watch dc and probably you want
to open and i was like yeah and we just
kind of we just kind of been you know
it's like my family now so you know um
opening for him and and you know having
him believe in me you know it was pretty
cool because i would just be like home
chilling and somebody would go hey dude
burr just called you a beast on his
podcast and i it meant a lot because i
knew bill doesn't put that out there and
i know bill's not somebody to ever give
one thing he always says is like you
never give false hope so i know bill
would never [__] go on his podcast to
his fans and say that you know say the
nice things like that paul versus the
beast it meant a lot because i knew
it's funny i'll actually see his name
right there on the wall yeah right there
yeah i'm pretty i'm pretty sure but so
uh
yeah i think that having somebody like
that say that is also adds to your
confidence because you're dealing with
one of the best and they see what you're
doing and they see your progression and
they start saying things they think
you're gonna do and it's completely
[__] humbling and it's like it it
gets you through
what are some of the biggest lessons
you've learned from like working with
him so closely
[Music]
you know i i don't know
i don't know if it would be lessons of
of stand up because we are just
different people you know like his his
approach is obvious like we're just
different but i think just kind of doing
something where it's like um
you're not leaving are you um oh are you
no no we've got two yeah oh yeah i'll
say goodbye well yeah when i'm done hang
out yeah two and a half minutes no no
it's all right we go longer oh word oh
can you open can you move pull that door
back the other way yeah there's a light
on it can you push it all the way back
yeah yeah appreciate it yeah yeah
um
you know we could go longer are you sure
yeah oh we made it we ran the light all
right um
yeah i don't know like you know bill has
his way i have my way but i think just
being
i think just being honest you know i
think just being [__] honest like
just like
you know
one you know
one thing i learned i remember one time
i told a joke and there was like an
exaggerated part of the joke
and he goes all right now tell me what
really happened right so it was like
yeah that's exaggerated but what's the
how did it really happen and then you
say how really happy he's like see
that's funny or as funny so you don't
have to do the so that was one thing
that i remember when i was younger you
know i can't remember the joke exactly
it was a strip club joke it was a strip
club joke i was in a strip club
and i'm like such a nice guy so i
remember like it like to like went like
that [__] like i'm nice and parts where
i shouldn't be
so i'm in a strip club and this chick is
just sitting there like you're [__]
man when was this dude
i was i was
where was i
i was in a strip club i was probably
like 18 19 years old whatever and this
chick is just standing there [__]
tits are out and i just was like hey do
you have a family
and she goes she goes yeah i have a i
have a son
and i remember being like what are you
doing here and she goes are you a cop
and
but but my
my version of it was like something
exaggerated right
no that's funny just her saying are you
a cop but i tried to make it some
different thing yeah you know like made
it more about her kid and her son and
like going into the you know she's got
pictures of her kids in the [__] lap
dance room and bill was like you don't
need to i remember there was a long time
ago i was like oh yeah so i think like
just doing [__] like that you know
because i was i was really younger at
the time when i would do that like it's
weird like you say jokes to somebody
like that and you're like now you're
like oh [__] i said that but i was young
of course you know so so uh yeah but no
just like
we're so similar as how we like treat
people man treat everybody with respect
and and just be cool we're you know just
kind of you know easy going get along
guys that like sports we have a good
time talking so it was kind of like
similar type of [__] like that so it
just worked it just worked yeah and i
love seeing and what we're all about
here at hot breath is like comics
helping comics and being like a positive
and supportive community for comedians
to develop
uh because coming up when i came up i
mean i
there it was i mean i came up in the
hood rooms of atlanta like white people
didn't mess with me like i went where
there was stage time i came up in black
rooms in new york it was the best yeah
because black black people are honest
like when you perform for black people
you got to be authentic and honest and
they'll laugh but white people you know
sometimes you can hide behind cleverness
but when you perform in front of black
people they're like well what's what's
the real deal here yeah you know and
that really helps you early on in that
just being white boy joel that's that's
how i came up in this game yeah yeah
that's cool right now i respect that i
appreciate that because i i did that too
do you ever get booed any like no rough
bombs like that um
no one time i was in philly and there's
some there was a place called the laugh
house in philly and it was a black room
on south street
and it was a cool room and i did my
buddies like hey if you want to go down
they'll give you like five minutes
and uh i mean i'm sorry if you want to
go down they'll give you 150 bucks and
you do like 15 minutes right you like
you co-headline or something so i go
down and it goes great
black audience goes great then he's like
hey man they want you back like the next
month it's like 150 bucks again you go
down your co-headline so i get down
there
and it's packed and they're tired and
they're tired and so many comics go on
and then this one guy
who was a monster comic i don't know if
he's if he passed away if he did rest
his soul his name was sugar bear
it was really [__] really funny like
a monster comic i don't he might have
passed if he did if he did rest his soul
but he goes on
and i go man this has been long he goes
on and he does like 20 something and
kills but they start to really get tired
he gets off and he goes dude now they're
tired so then i go on stage and i'll
never forget this i go on stage it was
actually i did a lot of
high pressure all black rooms where i
could be booed and this was the worst
out of all of and i did it for many
years and it went well so this one
didn't hurt me that much but it still
sucked because but i get on and i go hey
yeah i go dude i just got back from
kansas and this one this one black woman
in the audience just goes why
and i remember going this is gonna suck
and do it i was up there and like people
were just like a cup like it was so late
like two people would just get up and
leave and then a couple other people get
up and leave and a couple of people get
up and leave and by the time i was done
i was like half the room and i was just
like and they paid me and said thank you
and i just remember being like [__]
[__]
and uh you know that that'll stay with
you but there you know it was there was
no booing it was just like okay it
wasn't like [__] you're not fun i think
it was just like all right they're just
putting people on i'm tired he's not
killing the room the way you know i
would stay and it was one of those
things but i've had really amazing
experiences in rooms like that urban
rooms and stuff of course yeah white
rooms wouldn't put you up of course yeah
and anytime like a joke works in one
room but not like the other then like i
would get rid of it just because we want
to be able to entertain as many people
as possible you know but
there's a lot of
i don't in comedy there can be like a
lot of politics and things like that and
think what i'm so inspired about with
like what's happening at all things
comedy is it's like four comics by
comics run
and
there's producing opportunities for
comedians and it's so cool now more than
ever to see that there aren't
the gatekeepers as much you know like
trying to suck up to this booker or
trying to get in with this club or that
club which i was never able to do but it
seems like all those things are out of
control if you focus on what you can
control that's where you're gonna get
most of your opportunities yeah that's
true and and it's it's definitely let
you realize how silly it was to put that
much stock in those people i put eight
years into that you know people oh my
god i hope they like me oh that person
that never did this oh that person that
never did [__] stand up ever oh that
person that loves their power and loves
to make you feel like if you're funny or
not and now they don't have that you
know it's almost like they gotta [__]
stand down it's like it's like a
hard-ass general that now has to stand
down
you know what i think it's like it's
like stan the [__] you don't have that
anymore and it's cool it's cool because
it lets you know
that not only was it silly but like
it
like here's the other thing too it's
like it's silly because if that person
loses their job and then it's another
gatekeeper then it's just another it's
the same thing it's the same person it
doesn't matter it's like that person oh
yeah did you hear now greg does it oh
[__] greg's my [__]
yeah greg got hit by a train dude now
it's susan dude i got it susan's gotta
like me
susan pushed greg in front of a train
now it's her job yeah yeah susan got
shot in the face oh my god who's her
replacement let me go find it and it was
and it's all these people that don't
matter and and and and i think covet
made people realize that i think that
that that youtube and all that made
people realize that it just doesn't
matter things that you think are a big
deal aren't just get stage time and get
better all you do is get stage time and
get better that's it get [__] better
write more jokes be more honest get
stage experience and you're gonna
[__] murder and then murder and then
murder and people are going to see it
and go this person belongs in this room
and that's it
funny just get just get undeniable as
they say i think that's what barry cats
said yeah
that's the word everybody uses and it's
right just because you can't [__] with
that yeah you can't [__] with that yeah
that that's the thing is whenever
whenever i'm feeling a certain way and
then i see someone like you work and i
was like oh there's so much more to do
in terms of like just the
just to see you
effortlessly perform for 75 minutes and
i'm just like watching it just like
it's like inspiring but it's also a
little
disheartening of like oh my gosh there's
so much more
to like learn and do like as a comedian
you know it's like it's like a
never-ending rubik's cube it's just what
i love about it but it's it's just
inspiring to be around comics at your
level and hope like learn a little bit
here and there but realize
you know there's over 400 interviews
here and comics reach out to me every
day like oh this episode helped me and i
learned this joke writing technique but
the number one advice is to get on stage
every comedian that's been on here the
number one advice has been you got to
get on stage learn it all but you've
really got to get on stage and put into
action
yeah and one thing that i learned is i
learned this from a couple of comedians
and i remember
when i heard and i go oh my god that
makes now it makes so much sense and and
and and
it this is what they i remember i was
talking to maybe burst somebody go oh
man i don't even need to know who that
comic is because if that comic said it i
know they're a beast because this is
what they say is black belt [__]
and i'll tell you
so what it is is
i think a big growth spurt and something
that takes people to another level and
something that will raise people's game
and it raised mine and i do it all the
time and it does come with experience
because you know it's hard to do but
when you're on stage and you're [__]
doing your thing and you're about to go
into a joke
okay and your mind is going
[__] this joke i really want to talk
about this
okay
like i really want to go into this
i really want to talk about
school shootings or this abortion thing
or or or i really want to talk about i
really want to talk about this fight
that i got into with my wife about the
johnny depp case i really i'm this is
totally hypothetical my wife was
completely on johnny depp's side but i'm
using that but instead i'm going into
this bit that is kind of in my regiment
the better comics the the the elite
will completely abandon the joke that
they know works and go and talk about
something that's in deep waters that
they don't know how it's going to go and
that that is black belt [__] and that is
another level where you stop being like
man [__] that joke you know what i had a
thought today about this and this is
what i really want to talk about this is
what i really feel so let me do that i
might get back to that joke later or if
it fits but right now like i got 15
minutes left and like i kind of want to
do this and abandon the thought now all
this happens in one second in your mind
right two seconds but that's the
difference that that that is maybe
finding your voice more that is maybe
like yeah because you're gonna get more
from that
[Music]
uh joel you're gonna get more from that
you remembered yeah
you're gonna get more from that on your
ride home and going to sleep that night
than if you just go i did everything by
the thing and it killed and okay let's
go back to sleep everything's fine
you're gonna feel better going no no
dude i [__] i abandoned that thing
and i did this you know i live an hour
away from new york city i have two kids
i rot into the city i drive my car down
there does it make sense for me to do
every [__] joke from my special that
kills no
maybe i'll give them one or two on a
saturday night at the stand or the
cellar but you know what those five six
new bits i'm working on i'm gonna throw
that out i'm gonna let me do that
you know i'll find a way to get laughs
with other stuff if i have to but i
gotta make sure i'm getting this new
[__] out there and that that's that
makes sense that makes sense for the
work i'm not doing it for the [__]
money
spot money 25 on a weekend or whatever
40 on a weekday uh 75 or 100 on a
weekend okay fine that's nice to do a
bunch of sets and get a little you know
get a little pocket change but you're
doing it for the bits you're doing it
for the time yeah so you have to keep
that in mind because you have to uh you
know you got to look at long money you
don't look at short money
you know there's money and comedy wait a
minute where's where's the money there's
money in comedy when does that happen
you'll get there man i appreciate that
you'll do it the two white to fail face
awesome yeah well uh yeah let's lay on
this plane thanks for thanks for going
extra that that uh it's an honor and a
privilege for you to share your valuable
time with me paul um
before we get out of here uh is there is
there any like closing advice for
comedians a lot of comedy fans listen to
this but also like aspiring or like
young comics listen to this is there any
like advice you've learned that like you
always just remember that you would like
the younger generation to apply
the only advice i would give is
things that you think really really
matter
don't
and all of the things that you want to
get you will get if obviously i mean
obviously this goes with being talented
and funny so you know i i don't want to
give false hope and go but i'm saying if
you're a funny comic and you're talented
and you kill if the work ethic is there
and you're willing to [__] not care
about money at the beginning and go and
kill and go to hell rooms and this and
that and do all that and start to be
more honest and stuff it's gonna work
out but i would say do not put stock in
things or do not let somebody
who means nothing
make you feel
like you're less than
okay so that comedy club booker at that
club just doesn't like you or think
you're ready [__] that that means
nothing
that means nothing you go and find a
club that does believe in you and work
that club and do as many sets in that
club and then what's going to happen is
the club that said nobody was going to
start hearing hey man i heard
so-and-so's killing it'll all come but
like this oh they don't like me you know
i've heard of stories where somebody's
like i didn't i didn't get into the
comedy sellers i might move out it's
like what it's like you may move it's
like it's like
what
so you know it's it's just just you know
go to the places that people you know
believe in you and i remember bobby
kelley said something was my good friend
bobby kelly one of the funniest and he
goes yeah he's been on here and he goes
yeah he goes like you don't need
everybody to believe it you need one
person or two you know like one person
to believe in you just to do that you
know if one comedy club wants to work
you put in your available comedy club
and work and then slowly try to work
your way to other ones but do that don't
get so down about something and and
don't look at you know and short-term
and long-term goals
you know short-term and long-term goals
you know if you're like hey man i want
to put an album out in 2024 then you
make sure you put that out man 2024 and
then whatever your long goals are you
have those and write them down and if
you fall a little short one year you
fall a little short but those are big
man that's really big to do it because
you got to have a goal you can't be on a
hamster wheel you know if your goal is
to just do spots all over the city then
what's the end game you're trying to do
an hour you're trying to do a special
you're trying to act you're trying to
what are you trying to do you're just
trying to [__] you know what i mean
yeah yeah for sure and don't be an
[__] and drink all [__] night so
there you go amen well where can people
plug on all the uh awesome stuff you
have going on too yeah so i do uh two
podcasts one called the versi effect
which is by myself and sometimes with a
guest i co-host the anything better
podcast with bill burr uh both are with
all things comedy network
my youtube channel is growing i built a
youtube channel during pandemic and it's
going really well there's clips of the
podcast on there and stand-up clips um
all of my dates are on paulversie.com
that's v-i-r-z-i same thing with
instagram twitter and all that and i
hope everybody's in you know enjoys the
special on netflix yeah and my first
special i'll say this which was on
comedy central should be on paramount
plus two and my new one on netflix is
called nocturnal admissions so what's up
guys this is uh paul verzi and you guys
should listen to hot breath because this
kid joel is uh you know he's just a
great kid you know and um you know we've
known each other for you know 30 minutes
so
and in the 30 minutes i like the kid i
trust him and uh there you go so listen
to uh listen to his [__] and uh enjoy
appreciate you paul versus thanks for
being on hot breath my man thanks man